hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to bad dream coma now
we're going to the old house which I'm
assuming oh it's in the forest oh good
my my GU pursuits are still here but I
it has something to do with this kid go
away
no no no I'm gonna correct that one you
don't tell me how to do that I am the
master oh my god that's why everything
is torn and things just got flipped what
the hell well I mean I guess my pen ran
out of ink so I can't do that anymore
but that's why everything is like drawn
and that's why nothing makes sense
what's a trading card oh it's that guy
look out look out goodie looks you want
sausage oh but that starting to make
sense now I get it so there's more to
this than you'd think there would be
because it's all drawn it's all the
imagination of this kid it's it's all
part of a bigger world it's all part of
the world that doesn't necessarily mix I
got scissors I don't know how oh my god
that's why everything's taped up oh the
inner machinations of it oh the scream
settings oh that's why everything's a
scribble
oh I cut something out of this okay I
cut that out it's the rest of the gun
it's a picture of this I'm warning you
oh you ain't warning me enough flap you
guarding the house you creepy bastard
don't stare at me but this looks
familiar what is it treasure map
top-secret map key because this is from
the original games like this this year
this house I remember this it was all
piecemeal but I remember him oh god I
knew this was gonna have a payoff I knew
that it would there's some secret here
to be found there's something more to be
explored who wants this goddamn sausage
why do I have this goddamn sausage but
there's something more here there's a
lot more here and it's all has to do
this kid okay I get it I get it you
don't want me to go inside I get it I
get it okay but then according to the
map the key is in maybe it's not I got
the key anyway oh [ __ ] dude dude oh my
god that's so cool so I got the key oh
it doesn't go to that but that was smart
of me I should make it look smart
because I'm so dumb okay so there's got
to be something else for this key to go
to you right what would this be go dude
huh laughs you see now those
where is that mushroom Oh half-eaten why
is everything dying like if it's all a
drawing does it all need to be drawn
every air every once in a while and
maintained obviously he's erasing
something like I'm part of this drawing
and it's all getting out of hand that's
so weird
today more office did that guy's head
off keep it back
ah Pass okay I got a pass I'm eligible
to be here oh I regret going in here
immediately I don't like that whispering
I guess hello okay I didn't like that
[Music]
should I go back and get the fishing
pool I'll take that thank you Oh
somebody's I broke gasps happy day Oh
Poochie oh that's so happy I think you
want a sausage moon cut you out of there
or a crowbar you I don't know ooh wait
the Sun that's it I gotta cut out the
Sun and put the sea yeah it's bright
baby it's bright baby crowbar on that
cut it out oh I love the way that oh
that I could oh no spike
[Music]
oh it looked creepy at first but now I
guess it's okay
oh it's creepy again it's immediately
creepy hello I would do would you like a
sausage can I offer you a kielbasa
kielbasa creepy Oh
bye spike oh my god
dude you're spike and death in the
distance I'm sorry
no no what's going on there but all
right remember I don't forget it they're
the same now oh okay can't go in there
yet apparently
oh hi okay whoa oh why did I get a dirty
rag out of the out Al's that's
disgusting would I do that did they do
that myself
all right well anyway I just pick up
everything I find so dirty rag it is my
dad how's it going are you
[Music]
am i dead okay well apparently I'm not
dead but the door closed on me this
didn't didn't kill me yes sure is
merciful these days
alrighty then alright okay well duly
noted I guess I'll just be on my way
then
oh okay I didn't know I could break in
there well I broke in with the crowbar
okay and I and I go then sorry death I'm
now officially a criminal I'm breaking
and entering
Oh box [ __ ] you kidding me why'd you
do that
oh wait I remember that you want a
sausage sausage god damn I didn't want
to do that
ow owie I remember that in the original
game he had fingers cut off those so
cool anyway I got scissors though
they're bloody didn't mean anyway I got
him okay well I got scissors again
wait did it oh it took my scissors but
now I got them back okay but what can I
do with bloody scissors is that gonna
ruin it hasn't ruined my game yet so I'm
assuming that everything is well and did
oh oh I washed the rag oh it's clean now
that's nice oh that's real nice what am
I gonna do I return the rag who wants a
rag what's a nice clean rag oh oh you
want to Oh
oh that's the one that was screaming oh
I got a broom oh there's that car that
crashed earlier anyway that's nice
my god I got a broom - stay with me dad
I love you so much it's sad so sad
dear death please don't take my parents
you can have all my toys I'll clean my
room everyday I promise I know sometimes
I'm rude and impolite but I'll change
I'll do anything just don't take my
parents I beg you I'm sorry I have to
don't try to stop me
dee oh that looks like a lot of tacks
sweep sweep sweep can I have those you
want sausage all right anyway with that
alright
crowbar know who's down there happy
Mother's Day I love you very much old
families died so he's not a kid anymore
which is something that I was actually
suspecting like he's just a kid here
because like he's trapped in this weird
world that he's created or something
like that you know what I mean
like there's something more to it weird
I'm still bloodied up believe it or not
but I am just don't know why I got these
schizos though cover one of their heads
oh so he got married and had his own kid
[Music]
so weird
I get it I get it I get it is there
anything that that one's preventing me
from seeing not ooh is something here
sausage no glove now there's something
there though there's a drawer that
hasn't been opened yet maybe I'll be
able to open soon hey you still here
hell that's me going nuts took my stuff
Oh screw you no I don't think so
buzu hey it's back to normal I'm so
worried I'm so screwed all right but
there's got to be more stuff here yeah
that's all the same I'm just checking to
make sure nothing's changed so there is
something there but I'm completely out
of all my stuff that's the thing right
so where did all my stuff go do I have
any my stuff left was there a reason for
me to have those scissors and I've
already wasted that reasoning that's
entirely whoa give give give give yes
worms magnifying wait there was
something in that inventory list that it
didn't say glue scissors
give me all of those things I want all
of them but I think it's these are the
early drafts for the first game kid
didn't want to make games I did oh hello
teddy toy army to stop death I don't
like that I didn't see that before I
don't know how you stopped death maybe
you could dear death last warning yeah
no oh oh I need to be warned like 10
bajillion times you can't warn me enough
all right but I can't go here anymore
there's got to be something else right
oh okay oh I got a handle maybe I can
use the handle on the finger
I did it okay parents room basement okay
I need to take this take this through
that whoa never mind I'll just go there
directly then anybody want a sausage
down here your rooster you want a
sausage you CAC all right fine then I'm
fed up I've asked I've warned is it so
hard to understand that I want to be
alone I don't want to make people sad
anymore people are scared of me and
delay meeting me as long as possible now
when I finally decided to go away you
came along I won't go back to my tasks
no way I've just decided to erase myself
from this world once and for all you'll
be better off without me take the chance
I'm giving you enjoy your lives go and
tell everyone they don't need to be
afraid anymore
yours faithfully
[Music]
but I mean the world without death is
that really a world worth I mean I don't
know what does that mean you've unlocked
nothing I unlocked nothing then the next
episode is the last chapter apparently
why why deaths go away is death and this
kid the same person I don't know like
maybe not cuz it communicated but what
makes sense in this world it doesn't
make sense
ah but either way we'll find out in the
next video thank you everybody so much
for watching let me know what you think
down in the comments below and as always
I will see you in the next video bye bye